本日はなんと100万円企画第3弾遊苑長
カス切っておりまーす
yeah
卍がしたいだけなんですけどただいま呼び上げランド犯す切っております貸し切って
しかできない企画ってないかなと思ったんですけどあるどれもの特選的に撮り続け
られる
なかなか普段だと的なこのお客さんが入るとメイクかかっちゃってなかなかできない
ようなことができると思ったって6回はこちら
[音楽]
バンジージャンプでございますちょっと検証したいことがありまして感じジャンプ
行ったことありますな強いんでパンティジャンプで今回僕が係争したいのは
俺丸字ジャンプなんかに乗ったら怖くなくなるんだろうなって
今回の検証ではバンジージャンプは何回乗ったら怖くなくなるのか
継承していきたいとおもいます
がんばれ頑張りますさあ劣化どれくらいすごいのかを見てみましょう
can パーティーワンピチョコレ
それ本当にも認められそう
n ame
ティースん
ってくらい戻れるね猛虎はへ
お前強い強いマジでこれホントどうしよ怖いよ
昨日まですごいね
ねえ強い強い日左手で予定の一つでやれん
はっはっはこれは最後の政府最後の永続2
ターグはいっ
[音楽]
me
rar
分
car
ああああああああああああああああああ
わっはっはゼニトずっとこれぐらい濃いんです40
この恐怖心が
何かやったらなくなるか運命いうことで第5位
爪よねーはまずをチクチクしてるねー
様005位
命令関節も知っています千葉バーってこい
プロ待ってよ
ポイント8倍ほいこれ誰が助けデー
どこへ
ano
まあよく飛んだねこれでみんなでんかなぁじゃあもういいっ
[音楽]
うぁああああああああああ
me
うわあああああ
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ni
yeah
ああああああ
ん
2分
me
根っこがたはい1回目だと全然まだ若かったです
3はいいらっしゃい以外に
[音楽]
3回目ています
コアヒロ
nipa
ああああああ
あああああ
どうだった思ってるわかったすごい方だよさんね参考館に行ったんですよね
ここからいるならまあでも熱々を打っていくしかない気がしますね上がります
ブーブー do i know
を定めています
ん
利用あーん
怖いねん
ああああああ
フォアやー
wh
ああああああ
ブーブー sa 新学期たっ並木ます
me
4言っ
いや怖いわ売れ具合は母を連れてないんですねえ a 1
ああああああ
rar
ni
[音楽]
me
てるけど各地発明で持つ5回目
くださいん
ああああああああ
夜行が月大清掃が起こった鳥だった
生物学的な危機を突破
行ってきました6回目を下げています
[音楽]
me
いますやばい今不況ビシッと後部さんがいいときどっちが上
子が育つ家アーツとついたサーッっ
だの交換の痛みって強そうじゃなくて本当に本当に結構痛い
まずまーねこ霊夢とフレッナンパだよまあし
初です保育園へ登ってきますはあああ
泰葉
入ります
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
[音楽]
lean ん
ていません
[音楽]
me
teal
うううううあっ